Stranger Things is back with a massive slice
of 80s nostalgia and a new supernatural threat
to keep the residents of Hawkins on their
toes.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm delving into the second season
of Netflix's critically-acclaimed sci-fi horror
series to discuss the ending and some clues
about what it means for Season 3.
I'm also starting my Stranger Things giveaway,
so, for your chance to win a Funko Pop of
your favourite Stranger Things character,
just make sure you're a subscriber and leave
me a comment on this video with your thoughts
about the show.
Spoiler alert, obviously I'm discussing the
finale of season 2 plus other episodes from
the first two seasons of Stranger Things,
so take care if you're not all caught up.
Remember back in season 1 when Mike asked
Eleven to go to his school's annual dance,
the Snow Ball?
Well, at the end of season 2, around a year
later in the show's storyline, the pair finally
made it there!
But this is Hawkins, Indiana and, Stranger
Things is getting at least a third and fourth
season, so we know that things won't be "all
happily ever after" for our AV Club friends.
And to prove just that, as the camera moves
out of the school and into its parking lot,
it starts to rotate, taking us back to the
Upside Down, and we see the Shadow Monster
looming over the school!
So, why is the Shadow Monster back at the
very end?
I mean, didn't Eleven just close the interdimensional
gateway and didn't Joyce just drive the thing
inhabiting Will's body out of him?
Well, yes, but that victory is just a temporary
one as Stranger Things creators The Duffer
Brothers have specifically said that the Shadow
Monster will carry over beyond season 2, becoming
a main villain of sorts for the series as
a whole.
Let's look then at how our heroes defeated
the extra-dimensional big bad this season
and how their actions leave things open for
the monster's return in season 3.
Similar to season 1, the Season 2 finale finds
Eleven battling the show's monster once more
to save her friends.
El's role this time is to close the interdimensional
gateway, which is a cathartic experience for
her as she feels responsible for having opened
it in the first place.
Obviously, closing the gate requires an incredible
amount of exertion on El's part.
We already know that using her powers drains
her, for example, she collapsed after taking
out the agents pursuing her and her friends
at Hawkins Middle School last season.
Thankfully, her journey away from Hawkins
to meet her mother this season also led her
to Kali, aka Eight, another young survivor
of Dr Brenner's experiments, and she taught
El to control her powers by channelling her
anger about events from her past.
Given El's treatment at the hands of Brenner,
or Papa as she calls him, she certainly has
a lot to work with on that score.
Still, as she tries to close the gate, you
can see the energy she summons as she even
levitates, and the physical toll on her is
such that she bleeds from both nostrils.
But closing the gate isn't just about shutting
down an actual portal to the Upside Down and
saving her friends.
So, what else does it mean?
Well, think back to when Kali tried to persuade
El to stay with her so they could use their
gifts against all the people who'd hurt them.
In that moment, Kali used her powers on El
to make her see an apparition of Dr Brenner
who told El that, 'You have to confront your
pain.
You have a wound […], a terrible wound,
and it's festering, and it will grow; spread;
and eventually, it will kill you.'
Figuratively speaking, then, the gate El closes
is also the wound she has to repair in order
to heal herself of the emotional and physical
pain she endured at Hawkins Lab and of the
guilt she feels for unintentionally and indirectly
causing current events.
And like an especially bad wound, the gate
and the surrounding area are red and angry-looking,
they pulsate, and something nasty seeps out.
But as soon as the gate or wound is closed,
the scene is flooded with blue-tinged light,
a visual sign the characters have moved from
danger and rage to calmness and healing.
However, that won't be the end for our chaos-causing
creature as we see the outline of the Shadow
Monster behind the gate before El closes it,
and that monstrous smoky tendril that reached
out to try and stop El from doing her job
seemed to be forced back into the Upside Down
rather than destroyed.
Eleven does the heavy lifting, so to speak,
in closing the portal, but the AV Club gang
are instrumental in clearing the path for
her to reach the gate when, along with Max
and Steve, they enter the tunnels and set
the main hub area on fire, drawing the demo-dogs
away.
Something interesting happens here though
when Dustin gets sprayed by a huge flower-like
creature in the tunnels.
He's wearing a mask at the time but complains
the spray goes in his mouth.
Something similar happened to Hopper in an
earlier episode when he was sprayed and trapped
by the vines after breaking into the tunnels.
Both Dustin and Hopper seem healthy at the
end of the season, but I wonder if there could
be an incubation period for an infection that
may affect them next season.
When Will was recovered from the Upside Down
in season 1, he had a huge tendril in his
mouth which presumably infected him with the
slug he coughed up later.
I don't think either Dustin or Hopper will
be affected in the same way as Will, but the
hive-mind monster already showed how it spreads
itself and operates, and it's ominous that
at least two more characters have potentially
been exposed its influence.
And let's not forget, there's always that
demo-dog that Dustin and Steve put into the
fridge for safe-keeping.
Will, of course, plays a bigger role this
season than last as he becomes a host body
for the Shadow Monster at the end of the third
episode.
Mike believes Will has gained the power of
truesight with the ability to see what the
Shadow Monster is planning.
Mike sees this as a way for the gang to spy
on the evil entity; however, as we see later
in The Spy episode, it's the Shadow Monster
who uses Will to spy on Hawkins' residents
and manipulate events, setting a trap for
the soldiers in the tunnels.
The group eventually understands that what's
inside Will is part of a hive mind, with the
Shadow Monster acting as the central brain,
which Dustin likens to the Mind Flayer in
Dungeons and Dragons.
Mind Flayers are evil creatures with tentacle-like
heads that feed on their victims and also
enslave others with telepathic mind-meld-type
powers.
Mind flayers themselves are also guided by
a central elder brain, which in Stranger Things
seems to be the Shadow Monster itself.
And Mind Flayers also reproduce via tadpoles
that end up implanted into humanoid beings
where they feed on the subject's brain and
eventually take its place.
In Stranger Things, Will coughed up the slug-like
creature at the end of the first season and
the way he slowly loses his memory and identity
to the Shadow Monster in Season 2 parallels
the idea of Mind Flayer tadpoles slowly eating
humanoid brains.
Joyce understands that this entity inside
Will is like a virus and so she sets about
exorcising the demon-like spirit from Will's
body by tying him up in front of a fire and
electric heaters.
This works and we see the Shadow Monster leave
Will's body and escape out of the cabin into
the night sky.
This is a victory for Joyce in saving her
son yet again from the evil behind the Upside
Down, however, it hasn't necessarily been
killed, just temporarily banished and is waiting
to return.
So, did you enjoy Stranger Things season 2
and do you have any theories about the ending
or anything else from the season?
Or perhaps you've got a theory about season
3?
Let me know what you think in the comments
below and also make sure you subscribe for
a chance to win my Stranger Things giveaway!
And congratulations to the winner of my Blade
Runner 2049 giveaway, who's on screen now.
If that's you, make sure you contact me so
I can get your details to send you the prize.
If you liked this, I really appreciate you
hitting that like button, plus you can check
out more videos here.
I'll be posting new Stranger Things and Thor
Ragnarok videos shortly so turn your notifications
on for Flicks And The City to get them as
soon as they're ready.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!